I've been wanting to live more this way
for quite a few years living in a tiny
house in a natural manner has its
benefits but also has many challenges I
think is really powerful
we prefer using humanure which is a
method of turning human waste into a
resource that you can put on your plants
and use the nitrogen that is in human
waste
we use a similar process with our food
scraps instead of sending them to the
landfill we put them in our worm bin and
the worms turn them into compost we
maximize this small space by growing as
much food as we can
we have rabbits and chickens for meat
source and eggs we've been making
sausage out of the rabbit of course we
make stock out of the bones stuff like
that
we want a little closer to the land and
essentially our main goal right in life
right now is to reduce the amount of
things that we need to buy which reduces
the amount that we have to work so our
lives aren't just focused on money